good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to Barnes & Noble Upper West
Side tonight I have the distinct
pleasure of introducing authors Jonathan
Allen and Amy Parnes Jonathan Allen has
covered national politics for Politico
Bloomberg and Vox he is the head of
community and content for side wire and
writes a weekly political column for
roll call Amy Parnes is the senior White
House correspondent for the hill
newspaper in Washington she covered
hillary clinton during the campaign and
we'll cover the trump administration
they have written the acclaimed
biography hrc tonight they bring us
their new book shattered inside Hillary
Clinton's doomed campaign through deep
access to insiders from the top to the
bottom of the campaign Jonathan Allen
and Amy Parnes have reconstructed the
key decisions and uncie's opportunities
the well-intentioned miss fires and the
hidden thorns that turned a winnable
contest into a devastating loss Michiko
Kakutani of the New York Times writes
although the Clinton campaign was widely
covered and many autopsies have been
conducted in the last several months the
blow-by-blow details in shattered and
the observations made here by campaign
and Democratic Party insiders are
nothing less than devastating sure to
dismay not just her supporters but also
everyone who cares about the outcome and
momentous consequences of the election
so without further ado please join me in
welcoming authors Jonathan Allen and Amy
Pond
[Applause]
good evening thank you for coming I see
family friends and people we don't know
yet so there's my family waving over
there they must have been drinking
already they're laughing like they were
so I think what we're gonna do here is
read a little bit of one of the early
chapters of the book chapter seven and
then we will we'll talk a little bit
about what our process was and then
we'll take questions from everybody or
from anybody who has a question do you
want to start Amy we're gonna read a
little part of chapter seven which is a
chapter that centers around Iowa it's
called I was certain we were going to
lose Bill Clinton was pissed off he
hollered at John Podesta loud enough to
be heard through the walls of the little
auntie room he laid claim to you on the
tenth floor of the historic savory hotel
in downtown Des Moines Iowa it was the
goddamn pundits he was watching on TV
they were getting it all wrong again as
the results of the Iowa caucuses
trickled in Hillary was leading but it
was going to be tight
oMG Wolf Blitzer said on CNN it doesn't
get a whole lot closer than that that
assessment invited parallels to
Hillary's 2008 loss to Barack Obama it
was in Bill's view an absurd comparison
after all that had been a three-way with
race and she was still likely to come
out the winner on this night not the
third-place finisher but journalist saw
an upstart challenger competing with her
in Iowa and deja vu was a hard storyline
to resist the outcome tonight ensures
that this race is going to go on for
months and months on the Democratic side
Blitzers colleague Jeff Zeleny reported
that night from from Sanders
headquarters the perception all night
had been that Hillary was such a
prohibitive frontrunner heading into the
Democratic nomination fight that she
should have cleaned up easily
bill had a much different perspective
Iowa had never been Clinton country and
Hillary had increased her share of the
caucus return from under 30 percent in
2008 to 50 percent give or take a little
in 2016 Plus unlike Obama Bernie was
tailor-made for Iowa the state is
overwhelmingly white littered with
colleges and decidedly working class
working class cities even if Bernie
managed to eke out a victory that was
Hillary showing strength not weakness
why couldn't they see the difference on
one level it was just another of bills
routine fits about television
personalities he'd curse Tim Russert's
named after the Meet the Press host had
declared Obama the winner of the 2008
primary in May of that year but it was
another sign of his inability to tamp
down his emotions at pivotal moments of
his wife's political career at the start
of the day he'd gone for a walk with his
aides to release some of the building
stress and at one point he played oh
hell a combination of card games spades
and and [ __ ] with them he was a
protective husband and a concerned
Democrat and now he was shouting eight
years of pent-up frustration at his
longtime friend and advisor when bill
had spent himself Podesta calmly walked
into an adjoining space that was part of
the Clinton's suite for caucus night
there amid Hillary's phalanx of
anxiety-ridden consultants he found the
man he was looking for iowa state
director matt paul balding respectable
bespectacled and in his mid-40s
paul had left his job as communications
director for Agriculture Secretary Tom
Vilsack to run Hillary's Iowa operation
he had been with her at stops across the
state for the better part of a year
having served on Howard Dean's
presidential campaign in Iowa and as a
former aide to Vilsack and Senator Tom
Harkin Paul knew the state's electorate
as well as anyone Podesta beckoned Paul
with a quick but pointed nod you go in
there and deal with them
Paul gathered himself and walked in to
find the former president sitting in a
leather chair bill was wearing a suit
and a pair of leather gloves his arms
were crossed even if the yelling hadn't
been audible through the walls of the
boutique hotel it would have been clear
that he was in a foul mood his eyes were
fixed on Paul if there's ever a time to
make sure I know my [ __ ] the staffer
thought this is it
bill fired questions at him what's still
outstanding in Polk County
what about Johnson County and how about
Cedar Rapids Paul walked bill through
the state and where caucus results still
hadn't been reported county by county
slowly the president's anger subsided
even if his anxiety didn't Hillary had
gotten out to a lead consistent with
where her team thought she should be she
would be heading into caucus night she
was up a handful of points but Sanders
was slowly closing in on her after Paul
briefed bill the two men repeated their
conversation in the nearby room where
the rest of Hillary's team was nervously
assessing the situation even in front of
the others billboard out on Paul one
source in the room noted a market shift
and Bill's personality usually when
you're with him he's a storyteller this
source said on this night he was just an
information gatherer
he wanted to know what the staff didn't
know and why they didn't know it it's
much harder to figure out who's winning
a caucus state and particularly in Iowa
because the world's results aren't
measured in votes cast instead they're
reported as the number of state delegate
equivalents based on the proportion of
the vote that each candidate gets from
his or her performance at caucus
locations the numbers can come in as
very small fractions over and over Paul
gave updates to the former president or
more often reports that weren't actually
meaningful updates but remained upbeat
if not rosy about Hillary's chances of
pulling it out Paul concluded that what
really matters which caucus sites in
Polk County remained unreported if they
were in the core of Des Moines Hillary
was screwed if they were outside the
city she would win pollster John
Anzalone II who also knew this state
like the roads around his Alabama home
look
the state numbers same numbers and got a
bad feeling
he backed channel to Podesta while Paul
was reporting to Bill this is not
getting better he told Podesta this is
going to keep going down he could
overtake us let me just say before we go
any further we're really happy to have
c-span here every we love c-span there's
sort of a like local television for for
us Washingtonians and we really like to
thank Barnes & Noble for hosting us we
found out as we were walking in here
today that that this book showed up as
number one and on Barnes and Noble on
their website today across the country
so we're really happy to be here and
we'd really like to thank our team at
crown publishing or edit or Kevin
Downton's over there along with Rachel
were kooky and was wet so and many other
people helped make this book possible so
we would be remiss in not mentioning
them because they because they stand
along the wall and cheer us on and
they're really responsible for a lot of
what actually appears in the book so I
think what we were thought would might
be interesting for you as we talked a
little bit to each other kind of
interview with each other for a few
minutes and then take some of your
questions did you want to kick it off
Amy sure I think this is kind of fun
because even though John and I have
worked together now for two books and
five years I think we still don't really
I have an idea of John's favorite
moments and the inner workings but but I
I kind of don't too so I figure we'll
kick it off this way and then we'll let
you guys chime in as well so maybe let's
start off by talking about your favorite
moment of the book so there was an
interesting thing that happened on
election night you guys might have had a
similar experience to us which is that
we were expecting Hillary Clinton was
going to be the next president in the
United States and unlike us I assume
most of you were not well into writing a
book about this election and one of the
first things that we discussed in the
immediate aftermath of
of the election I think there were a lot
of people trying to get adjusted to the
surprise of the election to of course
the transition for us we we sort of had
to make an assessment of what we're what
we were gonna go still had to go after
that was from the the pre-election
period from the pregel period and what
were the things that we were really
going to need to focus in on at the end
of the campaign and in a different way
than we had before because we had a lot
of reporting from before the election
and then but some of the you know the
last month or two we hadn't had a chance
to really talk to folks on the campaign
because they really shut down around the
election you know nobody wanted any
leaks out so we were gonna have to do
all new reporting for the the last month
or two of the campaign and then go back
and get some things from earlier and one
of the decisions we made early was that
we thought that it would be a tremendous
failure on our part if we did not get a
tick-tock of election night of what was
going on behind the scenes in the
Clinton campaign and so my favorite part
of the book and the thing that I feel
most invested in is the effort that we
went to to to really talk to a lot of
people about what they were what was
going on and we have sort of a three to
four location tick-tock of the peninsula
hotel where Hillary Clinton and her top
aides were in a suite and and some other
rooms around it all night a boiler room
in midtown Manhattan where her data
analytics folks and her pollsters and
some of the people who are really
crunching numbers and and talking to
people out in the States where they were
all working there was the Brooklyn
headquarters there were people there as
well and of course the Javits Center
where her victory party or planned
victory party was and we spent a
tremendous amount of time trying to
piece together what happened
putting together a tick-tock trying to
get the time element and there are a
tremendous there there are a lot of
things in this book that have not
appeared anywhere else
Amy and I were the first to report in
late November because we were afraid
somebody was going to report it before
the book came out the President Obama
had urged Hillary Clinton to concede
when she was not yet ready
on election night but there's a lot more
of that story of election night what was
going on what the feelings were what the
emotions were what the debates were
among her staff and among her family
even and so to me that's the part that
I'm most proud of is that we got all
this reporting that that no one else did
about this really incredibly shocking a
moment for not only for the country but
obvious obviously for the the Clinton
people and not only for the Clinton
people but the country as well so you
what's what's your favorite part of this
book well that obviously cuz it took a
lot of work and what you're about to say
I should say if you don't mind
every authors favorite part is the
byline so this is really the second part
second favorite part no it was great to
actually I think everyone wanted to know
what was going on inside that room so I
would have to agree with you I also we
wanted to know the real story we wanted
you know obviously they kept trying to
portray a joyful campaign and we kept
seeing signs that it wasn't such a
joyful campaign so John and I kind of
made it a mission I think to to get the
real story from people and you know
initially people would be like oh yeah
it's great it's going well and slowly
slowly we started hearing the real story
and we were interviewing one source
actually in the Brooklyn headquarters
because this story is about the people
in the Brooklyn headquarters mostly and
a source actually told us at the very
tail end of the interview yeah there was
one moment right after Michigan she was
really pissed off but I can't really
tell you anymore
you're gonna have to talk to other
people who were in the room for that and
I was so angry I was like come on tell
us a little more about what happened
here we want to know about it he was
like no no talk to talk to some other
people in the room and I got him to tell
us who was in the room and and he gave
us these names and we tried to make it a
mission
in every interview after that to find
out what exactly went down in that
moment finally we circled back months
later nine months later we could
separately we could have had children
[Laughter]
love you honey
finally this one source I said come on
we really want to know what happened
here we kind of have bits and pieces of
what happened
this was post-election now wasn't it no
it was before you spoke no no
post-election yeah this was like it was
like pre inauguration but like I think
it might have been after Christmas yeah
so finally source tells us what happened
and and basically it resulted in us
finding out that she was really
frustrated by what had happened in
Michigan during the primary she was
angry at her aides she was telling them
our message isn't resonating what's
happening here these are the moments
that make this book what it is it's a
real book about what happened told
through the people not through outsiders
told through the people inside the
campaign and I think that kind of book
that kind of moment shines in this book
and this is what we aim to aim to do
return
truth or dare I I want to know what you
think the hardest part of reporting out
this book was I think getting people in
clinton's orbit to talk about anything
is impossible and i mean i you know if i
were so like chalk up like what am i
proudest accomplishment it's just as a
reporter it's like breaking into this
circle and getting people to tell us
stuff because this is a famously
especially in this campaign of a group
that was not leaking a lot not talking a
lot very afraid of the repercussions of
having you know having leaks come back
on them that's something that we write
about here that hillary clinton was
obsessed after 2008 with yet not having
leaks she believed that the leaks from
her campaign had really hurt her in 2008
rather
and seeing them as symptoms of some
dysfunction or accepting that there were
people who didn't feel their grievances
were being aired effectively internally
turning to the outside she looked at the
leaks as something that was plaguing her
campaign and one of the big reasons she
lost this time around all these people a
lot of these people thought they were
gonna be working in an administration a
lot of them thought they would be
working in the White House there was a
lot of incentive not to bring problems
not to air problems externally and not
to even air them internally and so I
think you know to me the hardest part
was getting people to talk and and it
really was unlocking person by person
detail by deep detail going back to the
same people over and over again matching
what somebody said in April with what
they said in September with what they
said in December and it was a reminder I
mean the whole process I think was a
reminder of the thing that that
reporters really know in their hearts
which is that if you want to get
something good you just have to work at
it and work at it and work at it and you
know I'm proud that we were able to
bring to light so many things that
people didn't know just in terms of the
basic story I mean you know you can
agree with conclusions you can disagree
you can look at things that are in this
book and say you know I don't I don't
think you know their analysis of that is
right or I wish they'd had more about
that but at the end of the day there is
a ton of new reporting in this and I'm
so proud of that and it was hard work
for us and you know I you know I know my
family sacrificed for your family
sacrifice for it and so I'm proud of
that now I want to know from you what
your biggest fear is now that it's out
because you know we've been sitting on
this finished product for a few weeks
waiting for it to come out and then you
know just to read you into the
experience of an author I think we can
say this I hope her publishers don't get
mad at us we heard that there was likely
to be a review on on Friday the first
review was likely to come out on Friday
and it came out before we expected it to
and it was really very good but four
weeks you sit around with a finished
product that nobody else has read you
don't know if anybody's gonna like it
you don't know if it's gonna sell and
it was just as hard to write no matter
whether those things go well or poorly
and so it's it's but now that it's out
and people get to look at it this
finished product like what is your fear
so many fears but um you know I want
people to understand that you know we've
gotten all we've gotten some feedback on
Twitter and other social media that you
know we're biased reporters or you know
we we went into this basically trying we
shoot from the hip we were trying to
tell we're reporters we wrote what some
people thought was a largely sympathetic
book the first time around this one is
basically what we what we saw what we
heard from everyone in the campaign and
so I I kind of want people my big fear
is that this will be misinterpreted and
as we explained in the introduction we
actually went about reporting this we
thought obviously that she was gonna win
and our reporting changed it well it
didn't change but our the direction
didn't even really change because we had
seen signs of problems all throughout
the campaign but what happened was she
lost we had to kind of quickly come to
we to interview people and quickly form
conclusions about what happened and and
do that right after the election in
before in January and that was a really
quick turnaround and so I kind of want
people to understand that process
without judging how we did this and
whether or not we were taking sides and
who we voted for and a disclaimer I
don't vote even because I feel like my
reporting is my public service and I
don't take sides and so and I I want
people to kind of judge this fairly and
not and to kind of read it before they
actually judge it if I could just add to
that I think one of the and you were
getting that's the you know before the
election happened we had picked up as
Amy was saying on a lot of problems in
the campaign and we had picked up on
some of the misery in the campaign and
we had picked up on Hillary Clinton
feeling like she didn't have a
handle for the electorate and there are
a couple of anecdotes in this book about
her basically saying to people quote
very close to her I don't understand
what's happening with the country right
now I don't get it
which we obviously saw was a problem in
terms of you know in the Democratic
primary and in the general election and
we're you know regardless of the popular
vote totals certainly she would like to
have gotten a larger share of the
popular vote and certainly in the in the
right states for the electoral college
there was something that Bernie Sanders
and Donald Trump were tapping into that
she had a lot of trouble understanding
part of which I think was her general
belief not just general but she's very
strong belief in systems and working
inside the system to make change rather
than breaking down the system to make
change but we saw all of this going on
for months and months her inability to
really touch what was going on in the
country and dysfunction on the campaign
and then but it was weird to us cuz we
saw the polls and were like well she's
gonna win because we're looking at all
the polling and the polling not only
says she's gonna win but like you know
with a pad you know there's seem to be a
pretty good pad there and I hope I'm not
talking out of school too much here at
one point our editor said to us before
the election said to us you know this
book's makes it like it sounds like
she's she's gonna lose like I don't like
I don't I know I'm having trouble
understanding cuz it looks like she's
gonna win and everybody thinks she's
gonna win and you guys think she's gonna
win and but this book feels like
something where she's gonna lose and we
were like yeah that's a problem we're
we're we're gonna have to figure that
out but we're like look we're reporters
this is this is what's going on and it
may be that you know these are you know
forward projections of what might be
difficult for an administration if she
wins but you know we're struggling with
that and then on election day she lost
and it was like we had seen all these
signs and obviously was close enough
that election could have gone either way
so you know any number of things could
have tipped it one way or the other but
but we had seen all these signs and and
not necessarily and I mean we trust our
gut in terms of just doing the reporting
and I think that paid off and I think
it's the reason we were able to produce
this you know fairly quickly after the
election
because we didn't have to pull up a lot
of roots and you know reformulate
assumptions because we just sort of laid
out what the reporting was okay let's do
one more quick question and then we'll
take let's make this a lightning
question okay what what is your favorite
quote from the book that's wrong my
favorite quote from the book you mean
like that somebody else said that's
someone else they're like something we
wrote that we think is so awesome I'm
sorry you stole mine yes yes not only am
i sorry not only do I apologize for
taking all this time the quote the quote
the longer quote is mr. president I'm
sorry yeah I would have to agree I can
give you another one if you want I'm
gonna take that one I'll actually know
what I don't want to use that other one
people should get to that they should
yeah sorry like Abbott and Costello or
Dumb and Dumber up here anyway we'll
open it up to questions because we want
to hear from you all so I do have a Q&A
mic here just raise your hand and I'll
come to you hi I'd like to know if you
have any theories as far as why former
Vice President Biden didn't one and
secondly I'd like to know how much
influence do you feel President Obama
had him as far as who could challenge
Hillary Clinton if a candidate would
have had a fair chance and lastly why do
you think on President Obama did
important hit of Hillary Clinton I would
have that made a difference maybe I'll
take the first question I'll take the
third
so Biden let's let's go there first we
have a I think if you talk to sources
and we did about why he didn't run it
was bad timing for him he needed to make
a decision pretty quickly his son had
died tragically a few months earlier he
wanted to make a decision over the
summer the clock was ticking his his
donors kept calling and wondering what
was taking so long he was really feeling
the weight of that moment and the
pressure finally he you know fall crept
in and he realized that he had to make a
decision meanwhile Secretary Clinton was
boxing him in and doing things that
allowed didn't allow him to kind of to
do what he needed to do she had already
taken many of the donors she at the time
has had run out and he wasn't he was
unhappy about it and we report that in
the book he confided to advisors and
donors that she was quote playing ugly
that's a favorite quote it's actually
one of mine
and he wasn't happy with it I think they
they have a cordial relationship but he
was really he was really angry at her in
that moment for kind of doing what she
did and keeping him out especially when
he needed time and he needed time to
grieve and make his decision and
especially now he's he's not ruling it
out if you hear him in interviews he's
he's basically kind of leaving that door
open and he I think he wants to run
again so I think he wanted to run then
but but the timing was bad and that the
actual decision-making was not in his
favor in terms of the pardon skip to the
pardon
no I I'll just take the last year yet so
in terms of President Obama he wanted to
remain neutral but everybody knew I
think everybody knew that he preferred
Secretary Clinton which I think you know
prevented a lot of Democratic candidates
from getting in or at least prevented a
lot of Democratic candidates from even
thinking about getting in because why
would you run against president
president's preferred candidate who
already has all these super-delegates
lined up for I mean you know she when
people talk about her skills as a
candidate one skill as a candidate was
clearing the field you know and she
didn't get Bernie Sanders not to run but
there were a lot of other Democrats who
might have run for president who did not
and the Democratic Democratic bench is
pretty thin right now in part because
there aren't a lot of candidates with
experience running for president as far
as a pardon goes no reason to partner
there's Jim Comey said that he wouldn't
recommend a prosecution he said a lot of
other things but he said he wouldn't
recommend a prosecution Donald Trump's
not gonna I don't think going to attempt
to imprison his successor no matter how
much somebody dislikes what he does or
compares them to tin-pot dictator 'he's
i don't think we're at that point right
now or anywhere close to it so there's
no reason to issue a pardon and they had
he done so it would have been a stain on
both the President and on Clinton and
her advisors to delete the so-called and
any consideration to the fact that
there'd be potential backlash of being
cover-up of something so I mean I think
it's this is a question in case people
didn't hear you know why she would
delete the personal emails the those
that were deemed personal from her
private server and whether there was any
fear of a backlash and obviously there
was a backlash in terms of people saying
that she was trying to hide something
the personal emails belong to her if
they are in fact of a personal nature
and there was a process that was put
together where her lawyers and and top
aides who are lawyers look through these
emails and determine what was a working
email and what was a personal email and
I think having looked at her work email
and having seen all of the information
that was classified that ended up in her
work email that was on the private
it seems pretty clear that they didn't
sit around going like oh this could be a
problem let's just delete it because if
they had done that we wouldn't have seen
all that classified information they're
not stupid they may have made a bad
decision bad judgment in fact I think it
was you know an epically poor decision
to set up that private server and one
probably motivated by the desire to not
have her files out there in the open
under Freedom of Information Act
requests while she was running for
president that worked out very well for
her as you all know but I but in terms
of the personal nature emails those
belong to her those don't belong to
anybody else so there shouldn't be a
problem with that as long as they're
making a good decision about it the
right decision about what's personal and
what's work given what you known now
through your reporting if you had to
pick one would you say the Clinton
campaign lost or the Trump campaign won
both I think it's it's really
complicated and we've been getting that
question a lot the last few days I think
as John and I report in this book and I
think we do so pretty conclusively it
wasn't just Russia or Co me it was a
combination of factors I'm not saying
that for everyone here who thinks that
Russia and Comey was the definitive
doctor not saying that it wasn't I'm
saying it was a contributor for sure but
there were other factors including the
fact that she didn't have a message from
the beginning of her campaign we detail
in this book a during her launch speech
she had more than a dozen advisors
working with her to write this thing
none of them really understood the
center of gravity of this message they
didn't understand where it was going she
brought in advisors from President Obama
a speechwriter
has his chief speechwriter to help write
it he actually threw his hands up before
the process was over and said I can't do
this anymore because the speech is going
nowhere essentially so message was a
huge problem for her
there was infighting there was inviting
at the top levels of the campaign her
two top advisors John Podesta and Robby
Mook didn't really care for each other
so much we detail this in the book
that's a euphemistic way of putting it
there there's one passage we have in the
book where you know they're there at a
senior retreat for senior members of the
campaign and they're basically telling
each other how they feel about each
other and they're using words like
passive-aggressive Hillary Clinton stop
talking to some of her top advisors in
Robbie milk during the primary these are
all problems that were kind of swept
under the rug they weren't fully
addressed she wanted people to think
that it was a drama-free campaign based
on 2008 and the headlines that had come
out from 2008 that there was lots of
infighting but you know they did a good
job keeping it under wraps but it was a
problem for her there was an image
problem a likability problem people
didn't trust her these are all factors
when you talk to people now you know
John and I talked to people someone
tonight who basically said I supported
her but kind of unwillingly and I think
that that spoke for a lot of people that
you know inside I think a lot of people
acknowledge that I have a competitor for
one of the best quotes from the book to
support what you were saying which is
one of her one of her top aides said I
would have had a reason for running or I
wouldn't have run and the argument was
essentially that even her aides didn't
know what the rationale was that they
were unable to look at what she was
saying and say here is her vision for
the country rather than her visions of
power and I mean she'd been running for
president for ten years at least and I
think I think an honest assessment is
that it was very easy to see what Donald
Trump's message was whether you like it
or not whether he was being honest at
the moment or not you could tell what he
wanted to do at a nationalistic message
he had a nice
this message he had an anti-immigrant
message but there were basically 1 to 3
things that you could all put together
and say these are his priorities this is
what he wants to do with his power with
her there was an embrace of so many
things and as some of them put some of
the people said to us if you're for
everything you're not for anything and I
think it was a harder message to carry
because it wasn't it wasn't very focused
even after all these years someone told
actually on that to that point someone
told John and I there's a wall there was
a wall in her Brooklyn headquarters that
had little post-it notes and it said
Hillary is four and the wall was covered
with various ideas and one of our
sources actually pointed to that wall
and and said basically what John just
said that if you're for everything
you're not really for anything you guys
talk about like Brooklyn you know
Podesta and look and Trump had Kelly and
Connally come come in late in the game
ran circles around them who actually
when you guys talk about Brooklyn
headquarters who was making decisions in
Brooklyn and saying go to Arizona week
before the election
you know the Rust Belt in the back cool
like look Podesta was in Millennials
didn't know what they were talking was
making decisions for the campaign so the
first answer to that question is your
guess is as good as mine oh um this was
a problem though that there there that a
lot of the junior the junior and
mid-level staffers were unable to get
decisions rendered sometimes they were
trying to get some sign off on something
they couldn't get it because milk and
Podesta weren't talking things like that
but in terms of if you want to sort of
look at what the basic debate was that
that really mattered in terms of the the
strategy of field operations and data
analytics and how the sort of mechanics
of campaigning look believed heavily in
the use of campaign data and not only
heavily but exclusively he didn't look
favorably upon those who look at
politics as an art including President
Clinton who believed that Hillary
Clinton should be out there trying to
persuade people who didn't agree with
her the data said it was more expensive
less efficient to try to get people
who disagreed with her to vote for her
than it was to get people who agreed
with her to show up which is true by the
way anybody will tell you that that's
true typically they don't abandon
persuasion efforts entirely and this
campaign increasingly abandoned
persuasion efforts and as they abandon
persuasions that persuasion efforts they
became more and more focused on the base
and they alienated it looked like they
alienated some of the people who might
have been persuadable at one point and
particularly talking about working-class
whites and this was a process you know
from the primary where she was so
focused on turning out with good reason
on turning out african-american and
Hispanic voters to win delegates to win
the nomination you you need to you know
to get to the nomination you need to win
the delegates and her path was to focus
heavily on urban areas and on
african-americans and on Latinos and so
she goes to you know to a city and and
works on turning out black voters and
Hispanic voters and doesn't go to the
nearby suburbs or doesn't talk in ways
that are trying to reach out to the to
the voter she's having trouble with and
they become somewhat alienated and you
see that process I think particularly in
the Rust Belt over time there's you know
there's no way to know what would have
happened had they done things
differently
but one of the the sort of motifs of
this book is that there was a big battle
over the level of reliance on data
versus say Bill Clinton coming in from
the field and saying like these guys
aren't buying our message we need to
spend more time with them and we need to
we need to frame it this way you know
he'd come in and milk would you know
essentially be like well that's that's
quaint you know your great great mr.
president it's awesome but I don't want
to send you out to a rural area where
nobody likes her I want to send you to a
city where we could touch more people
who are more likely to turn out and he
was really angry about it and a lot of
former presidents aides were really
angry about it and still are they kind
of said you know he he he was he had a
feel a better feel for things than this
data and analytics that they were
reporting back to him so I think to this
day that's something that's still kind
of angers the
people around him hi both of you
referred kind of in passing to James
Comey and how significant do you think
it was to the outcome of the election at
the letter that he sent to Congress just
before the election and even though they
kind of publicly downplayed it what was
the reaction to that inside of the
campaign there was a saying in the
campaign we can't have nice things
every time something started to go well
there was another shoe that dropped it
felt like there was a millipede running
around dropping shoes you know and you
know I we go through this sort of
background of that and I don't want to
tell a whole story here because you know
I want to get a few more questions in
but you know basically they were shocked
at what happened and they're trying to
scramble to figure out why the FBI
director had weighed in again and
weighed in to say that he was reopening
an investigation and essentially he was
looking at a computer that belonged to
him Abidine and and they were like the
campaign was like what there can't be
anything on there that we don't know
about because they got everything
secretary actually traveling with her
thought that when asked about it thought
that this reporter on the plane who is
asking about these new revelations was
joking
those have been a jerk like hey man you
see the new thing from Comey it's really
funny dude yeah so they they never saw
that coming and you know in terms of how
much of a factor II was in the election
I mean it's impossible to know exactly I
would point out though that that while
director Comey did a lot of unusual
things that's a euphemism well he did a
lot of unusual things during this
campaign all of what he was doing
relates back to that email server and
you know if there is somebody here who
thinks that was a good decision on her
part both in terms of you know how you
should behave as a public official or a
politically good decision on our part
please raise your hand
right I mean so you know that that is
self-inflicted damage and it may be
unfair and whatnot but you know we sort
of look at that as a know as part of the
major own goal to borrow a sports phrase
of this email server that actually
became too light before she even
announced the campaign thank you
I'm a journalist with a newspaper from
Norway I haven't gone away
I agree I have Norwegian relative so
we're very Pro Norway politics they're
much more interesting than they are in
Norway I have a question about your
access to the candidate herself I mean
did you ever or how much did you talk to
her during the campaign and to what
extent do you did you feel that her
staff was being guided in one way or
another when it came to talking to you
because obviously you knew most many of
these people from before from from your
other book and they must have known that
you were writing this book it must have
had some kind of strategy in place to to
guide you in the direction they wanted
you to go so that's a very complicated
question we don't talk about our
sourcing at all it's something we did on
HRC we're not doing it for shattered but
you can rest assured that we've talked
to everyone from the highest levels on
down this is a very inside the campaign
kind of book so if you want to know like
what outsiders are thinking this is not
the book for you I thought and we're
gonna say we don't talk to the press
it's caught the second part of your
question is also complicated because as
John mentioned earlier they're a tough
nut to crack
Clinton world we did this two times both
times we felt it was correct me if I'm
wrong but I think the second time was
just as hard as the first perhaps harder
because she was running a campaign and
they were worried about what we were
gonna put out we also had day jobs that
we were doing at the same time so and it
wasn't as easy as it might sound because
we did HR
it's not like they opened the floodgate
suddenly opened on this book quite the
opposite we had to work really really
hard we almost had to kind of
reintroduce ourselves to Clinton world
in some sense I used to joke with John
you know they act like they don't know
us and we've been working with these
people now for years one of the nice
things about some of the leaked emails
from the staffers where we were able to
see somebody being told not to talk to
us because they didn't they because we
presumably you know there was a whole
big reason it was just like yeah you
don't have to talk to them that spoken
to us before we're given red lights sort
of you're not a lot you know don't talk
to them which is essentially like you're
not allowed to talk to them but but I
will say this that there there's a mix
of that and over time that seemed to
ease and some people talked to us and
some people didn't some people asked
permission to talk to us and got it and
some people didn't ask permission to
talk to us and talk to us anyway and
some people John and I often joke that
we want to write it our next book on
someone who's a lot easier and more
accessible because this world is not
that like like Queen Elizabeth or hey
there journalist from New York and you
guys were terrific on a channel 5 this
morning thank you sir so aren't you Greg
right from Fox so I'm about a third of
the way into the book and so far Hillary
is indecisive she's got very bad
judgment she's not good at politics and
she doesn't really stand for anything
you guys have a front row seat
forgetting for a moment who's the
president now did you learn anything
that told you whether she would be a
good president because so far all the
things she's doing into campaign she's
not doing very well
would she have been a good president in
your opinion I think if someone else is
applauding is that what you wanted to
ask you
so the one thing that we learned from
HRC our first book was that she actually
she's a policy wonk this is her thing
she knows how to govern she knows how to
govern more than she knows how to be a
candidate I think she's that she's not
the best candidate she actually admitted
this several times during the campaign
she's not bill she has said she's not
President Obama either she's not even
george w bush who people say is quite
terming amy works hard says really smart
things and i cut in with a few jokes
everybody smiles and lasts and then we
get to go home and they for they forget
how much how hard she's will you know
worked and put stuff in so I you know I
sort of I feel for her on that level I
think you know when people talk about
sexism and misogyny in the campaign you
know I think it's societally we have we
still have a lot of that and that she's
she is sometimes you know judged
unfairly however your job as a candidate
is to win over people whether you know
whatever their biases are and that was
that was a little bit of failure and I
didn't mean to I mean I did mean to cut
you off but I I had a point that I
thought was yeah but I lost
it's tricky Gregg cuz I think that she
she's a terrible candidate she doesn't
know how to manage a campaign well I do
think she she's very well versed in
policy we saw that in the debates I
think that in arguably she won all three
and I think that she would be good in
that sort of way I think that she would
have a management problem for sure if
she was in the White House
just-just you all know if somebody
talked about combing since nineteen nine
since 1991 Comey was the one who led the
Whitewater investigation against Bill
Clinton and there had been a 91 billion
dollar industry against the Clintons and
specifically Russia started this
untrustworthy Clinton campaign so I
think what do you think be because I
think the press also contributed to that
since they were hardly ever asking who's
the president Donald Trump did you just
not want to say the words it's still a
painful undercovering never asked him
about his service whatever he said just
fell off like water off a duck back
nothing mattered and they grilled her
left right and center the Benghazi was a
phony thing and Gowdy himself was using
a private server so all these factors
that you mentioned also do contribute
but I think there was a very concerted
very concerted effort where in the last
10 days when Comey went and put his
thumb on the scales by bringing up this
phony email thing when he knew this
Russia Gate investigation very serious
level with the top spies was connection
to these people was going on so my
question is wouldn't all these questions
all these factors contribute towards her
being very cagey and mismanaging and not
having a specific message because I
think in the end her policies were not
very well reported by the press I think
if you wanted to find her policies they
were they were easy to find you know I
mean I I'd be hesitant to look at a
campaign and say and say wow there's a
you know a campaign against her and it
was unfair that there was a campaign
against her you know when you talk about
we haven't talked about this before but
about Russia you know here's an example
of something we knew we knew that the
Russians had been trying to tamper with
our elections we knew that they were
behind the DNC hacks there was good
reason to suspect they were involved in
the Podesta hacks and Hillary Clinton
made that case publicly she did it in
debates she said to Trump that he was a
puppet of Putin she talked about the
intelligence community the 17 agencies
that came in and said that Russia was
responsible for these hacks and trying
to do this and the country elected
Donald Trump anyway it is not as though
we had no idea what was going on here
and if people didn't pay attention when
they were voting and they're angry now
because they weren't paying attention
you know that would be one thing but I
don't think that's the case I think that
that was baked into the decisions people
were making one fifth of Donald Trump's
voters said that they thought he wasn't
fit to be President of the United States
and voted for him anyway and when I look
at that it says to me that even though
this was a very close race and one that
could have changed on just a little bit
it says to me that Hillary Clinton
failed to win by a large margin that she
could have that there were voters
certainly available to her if a fifth of
his voters thought he wasn't fit that
were available to her that she just
couldn't nail down and with that we do
have to move to the signing are there
any final comments from either of you
thank you we really want to appreciate
you all for coming and for a thoughtful
discussion
[Applause]